dans pourquoi on dit je vous raconte ce
qui se cache derrière les expressions de
la langue française alors abonnez vous
et n'oubliez pas que je suis cloche
salue les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux connaissez vous l'origine du mot
vaccin
[Musique]
au départ il y a une maladie la variole
au xviiie siècle elle fait des ravages
des dizaines de milliers de morts en
europe selon certains chiffres quand une
épidémie se déclarait elle pouvait
toucher 60 % de la population et emporté
presque un quart des malades
cette maladie se manifeste par
l'apparition de pustules sur la peau
douce on va riolas qui veut dire bouton
latin à l'époque on remarque que
certaines populations sont moins touchés
que les autres
c'est le cas des femmes qui travaillent
qu'à la ferme et qui sont chargés de la
traite des vaches
autre observation intéressante bovins
dont elle s'occupe sont quant à eux
affectés par une forme moins virulent de
la variole une maladie baptisée vaccine
du latin draka qui veut dire match en
1796 un médecin de campagne anglais
edward génère à une intuition et si la
vaccine des vaches protéger les
fermières de la variole il a alors
l'idée d'inoculer 7 vaccine à un être
humain pour le protéger de la variole
c'est risqué mais tant pis il se lance
génère griffe le bras d'un jeune garçon
james phillips et l'infect avec le virus
de la vaccine dans les jours qui suivent
l'enfant est chaude la fièvre monte les
au bout du compte il s'en remet quelques
temps après génère décide d'infecter son
jeune patient avec la variole cette fois
l'angoissé monte mais pour rien car
james ne tombent pas malades génère
vient de mettre au point ce que l'on va
appeler le vaccins et la vaccination
une technique qui permet de protéger
contre des formes sévères d'une maladie
en inoculant un virus atténué dans le
corps des patients
l'organisme développe alors des défenses
immunitaires qui passe à l' attaque
quand un virus en bonne et due forme se
présente
le vaccin contre la variole a depuis été
utilisés dans le monde entier et l' oms
a même déclaré la variole première
maladie officiellement éradiqué de la
planète
être en 1981 grâce à la vaccination
c'est vachement bien non si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser
un pouce bleus merci les épis curieux
pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]